charlie how are you my friend
good how are you dude i'm so excited for
this like all weekend i was like all
right
i think that i have probably
analyzed your tweets more than anyone
else on finance twitter over the last
two years let's just jump into how the
hell do you come up with the content
and how do you create so many of the
visuals and and graphics etc on a
consistent basis
yeah that's a question i get a lot of
it's i live it right it's i love markets
i love investing this is kind of built
up over years and years it's the process
of
looking at data trying to make it
simpler and trying to educate people and
give people context
right there's a lot of noise as you know
in financial markets a lot of
of uh sentiment shifts back and forth
and people
making bold claims in a lot of different
directions and i just try to give people
context and most of the time let people
interpret the charts and data
the way they want to right and just
giving people that context could be
helpful especially during times like
today
where we have a little bit of volatility
in markets
so let's jump into bear markets which i
know that you've spent a lot of time
analyzing uh yeah what is different
about the bear market that we're heading
into now maybe even a recession compared
to past ones
yeah it's it's it's a big [ __ ] a big
change i think anyone uh you know who's
been investing the last 40 years has
kind of seen one kind of federal reserve
right and that response is almost
immediate um you know when s p is down
10 15 you start typically start hearing
the chatter uh they got they should do
something either send a message that
they're going to expand the balance
sheet or cut interest rates some
combination thereof so the last eight
bear markets in the us
we've seen that exact response we saw it
in 2020 of course with the immediate
move down to zero in terms of interest
rates and then the biggest expansion of
the balance sheet that we've ever seen
but even before that in 2018 we saw them
immediately stop hiking rates and then
start cutting rates and launch another
round of qe uh so pretty much every bear
market even the 1987 crafts that's
really where it started under alan
greenspan
you've seen the fed ease
into that today very much different
situation the fed has already hiked
rates a few times and they're expected
to continue to hike rates to above three
percent by the end of the year so kind
of ignoring that uh decline in the
market and and the reason is because we
haven't seen inflation be the threat it
is today since the early 1980s so the
last time we had a bear market where the
fed took a hawk this position uh in the
midst of that was under paul volcker in
the early 1980s and we're faced with
kind of a a similar uh market today
except that the fed today is so far uh
behind that curve
so when you say that they're behind the
curve one of the things uh it feels like
is they were still you know doing asset
purchases earlier this year uh even
though they were talking tough at the
exact time like how do you analyze uh
what they're saying versus what they're
doing and is there any kind of
frameworks that you've um you know kind
of
distilled over time that that really
helps you separate words from actions
yeah it was just an incredible
disconnect right we saw last year even
even if you thought that you know
heading into 2021 let's say you had the
position that inflation wasn't going to
be a problem by the middle of the year
it was clear
pretty clear to everyone that inflation
was rising and and particularly in the
housing market we saw month after month
of record highs and and demand really
fueling that so there was in my opinion
and and i think any reasonable person's
opinion there was no rational reason to
continue to buy mortgage bonds uh last
year and into this year uh with the
housing market doing what it did and
zero percent rates uh just made zero
sense last year given the risk reward of
the situation so their number one job uh
you know as a fed under their mandate uh
is to control uh you know to have price
stability and you know they had the low
unemployment rate so that really wasn't
a factor and they just kind of ignored
it and uh and we find ourselves in the
position today where they're behind the
curve and so they have to be uh you know
rapidly catching up so uh you know
really the pain
that could have been avoided was just
that additional excess and upside in
terms of the mean stocks and everything
else in terms of people jumping into
risk forced into risky assets uh and now
we're seeing the other side of that
unfortunately why do you think that they
continued was it uh they just didn't
want to rock the boat was it something
like politically motivated was it just
ignorance what was it
yeah i think it's a combination
thereof uh the politics the fed
unfortunately has gotten more and more
political i think we've seen that in
recent years and especially with the
huge increase in national debt right we
added six trillion dollars that didn't
happen in a vacuum that couldn't have
happened without the fed monetizing that
and and buying a good chunk of that uh
debt and adding it to their balance
sheet so to me that was
that was really the politicization of
the fed and uh the fed has kind of had
this idea that uh the base case scenario
should be easing and and that started
under greenspan but it really
accelerated under bernanke and the idea
was that uh
easing should should always be
preferable because we're not really
worried about inflation and if you're
not worrying about inflation why not
ease why not you know just make that
your base case scenario of course
anyone in emerging markets countries can
tell you why right they've experienced
that and anybody living in the 1970s
could tell you why as well but it was
just too far removed from us
for that to be a real concern and so
you know that pass it on to the next fed
and same thing with what the government
does pass it on to the next uh you know
so we'll continue uh doing what we're
doing until we're really forced to uh to
move and now they're in the position
where
really they they've lost most of the
credibility i believe that they had but
if they want to retain any credibility
here they have to start moving higher
and it's only uh only because of that
they're really being forced to uh that
they're doing so and and so at a certain
point here we'll we'll likely see them
flip and go back in the opposite
direction but the optics today are two
are too much for them to just simply
ignore right we have the lowest consumer
confidence in history uh we have gas
prices above five dollars a gallon for
the first time in history you have any
number of factors but inflation is the
main reason people are feeling angst and
for good reason their wages are not
keeping up uh with uh with the inflation
now for 14 consecutive months uh and and
that's a lot and uh and so the fed
really has to try to at least do
something about it so when you start to
look at uh the data that they are using
obviously cpi is the thing that
everyone's been paying attention to for
the last year so uh i appreciate uh the
fact that we probably see eye to eye on
uh it's [ __ ] like there's just no
way that the cpi prints appear to be
accurate um and
can you walk us through like why you
don't think the cpi measurement is is uh
uh maybe reflecting what they think it's
reflecting
yeah the big factor today you know i'm
not one of these people who think that
historically and you know inflation was
ten percent and it was really two
percent you know
certainly it's probably a bit higher
than the reported
figures if you're going back let's say
20 30 years but
i think the big disconnect has been in
the past year or so
and looking at the housing numbers and
housing you know as you know is the
biggest component of cpi it's what
people spend most of their budget on uh
over 33 percent of that index is just in
housing and they just have an antiquated
measure in my view and they they have
some justifications for it of measuring
uh the cost of housing cost of shelter
we're really instead of looking at
market prices whether it's rents which
are up 15 over the last year or housing
prices nationally which are up over 20
which is the highest increase we've seen
year over year on record uh they're
going around and polling people and
asking them
what they would rent their homes out for
something called owner's equivalent rent
and when they do that apparently the
answers to those polls are much lower
than the actual statistics so because of
that you know that 8.6 figure uh if
we're using you know the actual housing
inflation that we've seen over the past
year uh you know would would obviously
be uh well above 10
so it's just a function you know that's
the big driver in terms of the index and
maybe and you know over the long run
that smooths itself out but you know
over the past year that's been just you
know really under reporting the actual
rate of inflation uh you know in the
economy how do you think about the
demand for real estate once uh rates
start to increase we have seen seen the
mortgage uh rate explode upwards uh is
this just a simple supply demand hey
demand cools the rates go up we should
expect real estate prices to fall and
like don't make this too complicated and
keep it simple
yeah i mean
it's not it's not as simple as that as
the stock market where it repla prices
very quickly but it has to impact demand
and we're seeing that already so the
mortgage rate bottomed at 2.65 percent
early 2021
and uh it's it's doubled since then and
so if you're looking at the the
payment right the average payment if you
put 20 percent down
it's pretty much doubled over that
period time and you have phone prices up
you know 20 30 percent uh since then so
uh if if that doesn't impact demand then
then nothing will and it is already if
we looked at new home sales last month
they've really collapsed and i think
we'll see that uh continue
uh and you know the housing market
you know this is really the second
bubble we've seen in in the housing
market and
uh it could have it to some extent been
avoided i i don't think it should be a
national policy that we've kind of made
it in terms of of the the fed saying
that we want want to create these
housing bubbles uh that and the theory
was that under the wealth effect of
people's homes went up in price uh then
they would spend more money and and and
that is true to a certain extent in the
short run uh but you don't want to
create a situation where housing is
unaffordable uh based on incomes we saw
that in the mid 2000s and now we're
seeing again today it's at the lowest
affordability you got to go back to 07
uh you know to see that and that's not
good for
an economy long run you want housing to
be an affordable
because it's not a productive good so
you know driving prices up uh you know
ahead of fundamentals for the housing
market's bad for everyone right it
increases your taxes increases insurance
uh you know we've seen all these things
go up so uh i'm not sure what the
thinking is beyond again that
theoretical concept which is we just
want asset prices to go up so people
spend more
uh
i think hopefully people will learn
after uh the housing market comes in
here and we don't have to see a collapse
like we did the last time but you have
to see a normalization you just can't
have long-term uh housing prices
stretched in relation to income it's it
you know it has to give one way or
another either you loosen lending
standards which we don't want to see
right we don't want to see it go back to
having subprime and people only putting
a few percent down or credits people
lying about their incomes that's one way
to avoid the collapse or two is we just
have to take the medicine and say at
seven times uh you know home prices are
seven times now uh they're above incomes
and that's the highest we've ever seen
and perhaps that's too much and perhaps
we shouldn't pursue that as a goal
you know as a policy right so just
letting the market instead of uh the fed
determine uh you know where housing
prices should be i think i think that
makes sense why do we entrust really is
a big question not just for housing but
for the stock market for the economy in
general why do we trust that 10 people
sitting in a room can determine the most
important interest rate in the economy
i'm not sure why we do that right we
wouldn't do that with food
that you know where we somehow we seem
to to go to the grocery store and have
food each week and there's not some
central planner figuring out you know
what quantities to put in different
amounts and how much to produce right
the market's driving that
so why should it be different with
interest rates we're really entrusting
these people uh you know giving them a
lot of responsibility and giving them
perhaps the the respect that they don't
deserve because based on history they've
gotten it wrong how many times right uh
you know and i won't say i would do any
better
right
but you know leaving them to determine
what the interest rate should be or or
when they should buy bonds or not buy
bonds and you know it just seems
misguided because it's going to lead to
a misallocation of capital right you're
driving people into asset classes based
on that interest rate that manipulated
interest rate rather than the underlying
fundamentals right of that sector so
why exactly are stocks crashing right
now is it because of interest rates and
the fed basically is pushing stock
prices down and they don't care how far
how far they fall
that's that's that's part of it i think
the interest rate story is more
complicated if you look historically go
back 100 years and you say
what happens to the stock market when
the 10-year yield
goes up versus go down you actually find
stocks tend to actually do better during
a period of rising rates than falling
rates and there's a number of reasons
for that and you know mainly because
when you have rates rising
growth is typically improving
and and earnings are typically improving
and that's typically good for stocks
situation we're in today is a bit
different of course because interest
rates are rising not because of growth
expectations but because of inflation
expectations and that tends to be
a difficult pill for uh stocks to
swallow uh you know when uh people are
worried about uh you know that pushing
the economy into recession i think the
the that's the fear today that's what's
driving this uh you know i did a poll on
twitter last week asking you know do you
think the u.s economy is in a recession
or not in a recession and 59 said it
said we're in a recession already so
whether we are or not that's only going
to be determined in hindsight and you
know it's not really helpful at that
point right the stock market's a leading
indicator of that uh and so people are
feeling uh that this is a recessionary
environment because their wages are not
keeping pace with inflation uh and at
some point that the expectation then is
that they're going to pull back on
discretionary spending that will lead to
a slowdown in earnings you're already
seeing margin compression with walmart
and target and a number of other
retailers and you could you likely see
that continue as they can't push the
higher cost on to the consumer so
you know why are stocks falling take
your pick right we have
inflation interest rate tightening fed
policy the war in ukraine of course is a
big factor and some of that is
self-inflicted in terms of our foreign
policy response to that has only
exacerbated the inflationary uh picture
in my in my view foolishly uh so we have
any number of reasons but of course
that's what dunn has done the question
is what's going to happen going forward
uh and if we look at the history of bear
markets you kind of have this
delineation between recessionary bear
markets and non-recessionary repair
markets and tend to see
bigger declines of course during
recessionary bear markets and they tend
to last longer so if this is a
full-fledged recession not like we saw
in 2020 where it was you know really a
two-month
drop and then you know we threw
everything at it but a more typical
recession like we saw you know in in
2008 2009 or or or before that
in 2001 uh you would expect uh you know
greater than the current declines today
that doesn't necessarily have to happen
but that would be the kind of base case
expectation we've seen recessions in the
past in 1990 where you had stocks
decline only 20 percent so anything is
possible but you know why are stocks
going down again take your pick
but really you know all those factors
and combinations with valuations of
course were stretched coming into this
year we had the highest evaluations on
the s p you have to go back to the
dot-com bubble and if we looked at at
the nasdaq 100 we had you know just the
highest valuations again going back
there so some of it's just mean
reversion right when you have you need
an impetus for people to sell
and you had these extreme valuations
particularly in high high growth area of
the market and a lot of that has been
reverted very quickly so far this year
so you know it's it's not going to be
easy from there this year from here even
on the short side because even in bear
markets that's when you tend to see the
biggest rallies of all so people have to
be careful uh you know kind of
positioning here from from from here
forward
when you look at the federal reserve at
one point the market was pricing in 300
bases point interest rate by the end of
the year 10 interest rate hikes uh
there's calls for it to get aggressive
when inflation appeared to have peaked
back in march people said oh maybe they
won't actually be as aggressive if
inflation comes down what is your
expectation given you know june of 2022
right now for the fed through the end of
the year do they just stay committed to
what they're saying they're going to do
do you see some diversions from that
yeah
look it
it's it's such a it's such an
expectations game right and we've seen
if you even if you're looking at fed
funds futures right uh
they don't predict the future very well
um so take all of that with a grain of
salt the fed's going to react to what
goes on uh in inflation employment and
the stock market right and you know
as we talked about this is the
this is the first time in a long time
they've uh you know been tightening into
into a bear market but and but thus far
it's you know we're down i think a
little over 20 you know 21
you know i think 22 i think that as as
of this morning's lows uh is that enough
for them to kind of pause or or or be
dovish probably not enough but if we get
to 30 40 percent uh you know in a few
months or later this year
the expectat my expectation would be
there would be some kind of shift in
language again just assuming the fed
is not going to do what paul volcker did
and they're not going to
kind of push you know deliberately push
us into a recession in order to bring
down inflation
assuming that's not going to happen then
you know if if those declines continue
it'll likely mean we're in a recession
at that point
and then inflation should be you know at
least moderating on its own you know
going into that and likely my
expectation would be the fed would at
least pause at that point uh you know if
not do an about phase so uh you know the
fed likes to use data dependent
you know and they've proven that it's
not so much data dependent but more so
market dependent uh but this is a
deviation from that so uh the fed will
hike 50 basis points this week uh so
that you know i think that's a done deal
probably july as well but i think
looking out any any further than that
it's going to be
all these factors uh kind of driving it
and the first chance that they see that
they can stop pause or move in the
opposite direction i think that they'll
likely take it because it's just going
to be too painful and i'm not i'm not
sure they have the stomach
uh or the willpower to do uh what paul
folker did in the early 1980s ronald
reagan gave him the leeway and you know
to push us into not just one recession
in 1980 but another one
uh from 80 to 82. and so uh uh i'm not
sure as a country
we're willing to we might need to take
it but i'm not sure that uh you know the
powers that be are going to
willingly do that so we'll see it'll be
interesting uh hopefully they'll do the
right thing right for the long term and
not be short-term thinking and there's
no magic number right in terms of the
fed funds rate but you know
it they it cut it immediately to zero i
think the reasonable question is today
is why not why are you not treating this
as a as a similar type of crisis on the
upside right uh and they could very
quickly quell demand it's probably uh
already coming down but if you know why
not just you know rip the band-aid off
and go 100 basis points uh for the next
few meetings and then see what happens
um but how do midterm elections play
into this
like is there going to be pressure
politically
do not
push us into a recession before the
election uh and also do not have high
inflation and so like wave a magic wand
and figure out how to get this soft
landing
yeah there'll be a choice i'm not yeah
i'm not i'm not sure that i think the
fed will worry about their own you know
how their own optics before saving you
know you know the the powers in charge
today i think
so i i'm you know if they were going to
stop they would have telegraphed that i
think ahead of that i think the midterms
at this point
are pretty much a done deal unless we
see some you know unforeseen event
you're just going to see a landslide in
the opposite direction uh because of the
consumer sentiment numbers because of
the stock market because of what's
coming in the housing market and
you know right or wrong people are
people will blame
the administration in power that's been
the american way and that's kind of the
balance and checks and balances and and
uh sometimes you reap the benefit of
that benefits of that and you get credit
for things that aren't your necessarily
you're doing and sometimes you get
blamed and you know not to say that
there there isn't blame to go around
uh in the current administration for for
some of what we're seeing but uh you
know they're going to they're going to
see in the polls that people are not
very happy uh with the direction and i
think that's regardless of what the fed
does from here talk to me about uh wage
growth one of the things that uh we saw
at some point when there was high
inflation was there ever chill out it's
it
inflation's good for you like you're
you're gonna get paid more money uh i
think we're
i think we're now at uh
inflation-adjusted average hourly wage
uh is negative for 14 straight months um
yeah
explain what's going on with wage growth
and inflation and like especially people
just getting screwed it's it's an
incredible thing and what an about face
right and i'm not sure powell this week
will own up to it but uh for for months
in late 2020 early 2021 he was you know
kind of saying even if we have inflation
that's a good thing and it's going to be
good for
uh the lower income segment of
population especially and you know i
push back and i think others push back
at that time
the data doesn't support that
that theory that inflation is good for
uh people with lower incomes because of
course it's going to be a higher
percentage of their income when gas
prices go up and food prices go up and
necessities go up it's going to hit them
the hardest they also don't have
uh assets right which have benefited
from the asset price inflation that
we've seen and uh so you know that's
that's kind of a ridiculous uh concept
that they came up with but you know they
don't seem to be saying it anymore
thankfully but
what's interesting is that
we've seen a really 180 degree
shift in terms of the way the american
people uh have uh felt about inflation
so in in 2020 early 2021
it was kind of this idea that
even if we're gonna inflation it's only
a good thing right people are saying
their stock portfolios go go up their
housing prices go up wages were going up
for the first time in a long time in a
meaningful way which is of course a
great thing and you want to see that
happen the problem is it was a mirage
right it's a function of a 40 percent
increase in the money supply uh and
giving out
three rounds of stimulus and paying
people more on unemployment than when
they were working
so you know all of those wage gains and
we've had you know pretty significant
wage gains uh you know since uh early
2020
uh if we adjust for inflation now it's
actually negative so uh you know it's i
call it mirage because uh you know
you're feeling like you're making more
money and you are in nominal terms but
uh the things that you're buying now
have increased by more so
it's a tough it's a tough pill to
swallow but really we saw a reversal
last year and happened much quicker than
i thought it would uh you know in terms
of of a change in the american psyche i
called it
where we went from believing that
you know
free money was free to essentially
saying no it's not for either a cost to
it and that's really what stopped the uh
you know build back better uh plan joe
manchin really drew a line in the sand
speaking for
uh you know the american people saying i
just can't do it anymore and that you
know that
is typically unpopular saying we're not
going to throw more money at something
uh you know if six months earlier
everyone was happy to do the third
stimulus even though the economy had
recovered and earnings recovered so it
was an about-face so really it's the
reality of the situation is kind of
showing revealing itself here and it's
happened much quicker than i thought it
would uh and unfortunately it's because
inflation has been much higher than i
think and happened much quicker due to
the increase in the velocity money uh
than people thought and so
it's a change in the psyche and perhaps
that'll stay with us for a while as it
did
after the 1970s early 1980s experience
and will have a healthy respect for it
going forward that you can't
print your way to prosperity right you
have to have innovation real economic
growth over the long term to
improve people's well-being and we've
done that over the last hundred years
but uh increasing the money supply by
forty percent and borrowing six trillion
dollars and sending it out uh you know
is not going to in the short term it's
gonna feel like a great thing and you're
gonna feel wealthier uh you know but
it's it's really mirage of course
because uh you know eventually that
inflation's going to seep into the
system
so what's so fascinating about this is
um
everyone talks about the debt everyone
talks about it and if you look at i
think global debt to gdp is like 350 i
think us is like 130
uh off top of my head and uh there's two
ways out one is like hey stop taking on
debt and just allow growth at its normal
rate or the second is
uh get our ass in gear
generate the gdp growth and like
basically build our way out uh
unfortunately or fortunately you i and
everyone watching this we have no
control over debt right like like
they're like and guess what they have no
incentive to stop so like they're going
to continue and party right yeah it's
just going on for 40 years yeah so like
we just can't we can complain about it
but we can't do anything about it but
the building side to me is the single
most important thing that we can control
and nobody can wave a magic wand and
create you know quote-unquote economic
growth uh for an entire economy but
everyone can do their part to try to
drive growth on a small scale if you add
that all up it leads to it
yeah let's say everyone tomorrow woke up
and was like all right let's get to work
can we grow our way out of it or is it
just we're so overwhelmed by their
incentive to take on debt that it is
impossible to grow our way out of it
no i yeah no i'm a long-term optimist i
guess we've been talking about a lot of
negative things here but no i i'm not
going to bet against the american people
and innovation and their grit and and
you know no absolutely not absolutely
just look at japan's debt to gdp we're
not we're not over the edge yet it's not
too late we have we have a chance to
turn this thing around we have to make
some tough decisions and again focus on
making those hard choices so that our
children and grandchildren won't be
saddled with this debt and and the
reason it's not intuitive right i think
for people to say well what's wrong with
it right it generates increasing growth
right in the short run what's the
problem in the wrong one with higher
debt and and
any nation that has had a a a
above a certain point a
you know a debt to gdp ratio above a
certain point what it does it starts
crowding out uh you know
other savings and investing right and
that's that's the bigger problem with it
and so you know we are we at that point
today and if interest rates rise is that
you know going to be a bigger part of
the budget and cause problems sure it
will but uh but we can we can turn this
thing around but we've done it before we
can do it again but uh it's it's it's
not going to come without some paint so
unfortunately you do need to have
corrections and recessions sometimes to
clean out the excesses and and will come
out of this stronger you know for sure i
think the american people are going to
continue to innovate if you give them
the freedoms
to
innovate and giving them the incentives
to work hard and create real uh real
improvements and products that people
want uh that's that's going to be a good
thing long term so uh you know the
upside of all this
volatility and corrections is if you're
a net saver if you have 20 years or more
uh you know any downside in the market
should be viewed as an opportunity right
you're getting the opportunity to buy in
at a lower price and that should lead to
better uh long-term returns and you know
in terms of uh you know the macro and
the debt levels as you said you can't do
anything about so focus on your
your business focus on uh you know doing
the best you can and uh you kind of have
to ignore that noise but
you know in some respects it's going to
change come november right in terms of
uh you know the the deficits already
coming down the money supply
last month declined for the first time
in 12 years 12 years we had 144
consecutive monthly increases in the
money supply and and then we finally had
a dip and i expect that should continue
with the feds starting to unwind their
balance sheet so we're already shifting
we're already moving in the right uh
direction we just have to keep it going
and a choice will have to be made
when you know the pain is really uh
being felt uh either we uh you know do
make the hard choices
or we say
this is too tough let's just go back to
you know printing more money or let's go
back to borrowing and um
i hope that we don't uh you know choose
that route but uh you know i think
there's incentive structures are are
still there to you know to to see what
happens but everyone's got a voice and
and i think the fed is hearing loud and
clear that people are are not happy with
the situation they're not just gonna uh
for the first time in a long time people
are even know what the fed is and doing
and they care about it because it's
affecting you know their their everyday
lives right and so same thing we can be
said i think that people are drawing
those lines much more than they have in
a long time yeah man i could talk to you
literally forever i i agree with so much
of what you're saying and i think that
uh what's unique about your insights is
that uh there are things that are
intuition there are things that you can
kind of feel in the market but you're so
data-driven and you continue to uh just
explain look like it is math it is
numbers and separating out the um kind
of data-driven analysis from the
emotional components of this uh is much
easier said than done i don't think
anyone uh
you know it's a weird thing where
psychologically like even if you don't
hold the asset like i don't hold public
stocks when i see the stock market kind
of like damn
right and like
i'm not getting hurt by it but it still
sucks and i think that there is this uh
ability of the best investors in the
world to separate themselves out from uh
that psychological impact and in some
ways almost have the reverse psychology
of hey prices are down if i think these
are good assets i get excited right and
i actually want to buy them
yeah i think naval once said uh and it's
great quote the difference between an
investor and a speculator is is what
your reaction is uh to when your
favorite asset class goes down in price
right if you're a speculator
you're worried you're concerned if
you're an investor you're excited right
so bitcoins down two-thirds uh you know
how if you're if you're a speculator
that's terrible if you're an investor
and you have a long-term view that
bitcoin is going to be higher 10 20
years from now okay then you're excited
and we could substitute bitcoin for any
any asset class high-yield bonds are
getting killed today or uh
you know any treasury bonds anything
right but that means the yields are
going up the reward is going up so the
forward returns are better in all of
these things than they were so we can
debate you know if they're going to go
uh further all day long right no one
knows the answer to that but we can say
that the risk reward is better today uh
certainly uh than it was a few months
ago right and so that's something good
for at least investors to start
you know being a little bit more
optimistic uh about and thinking about
you know okay well how am i gonna
navigate if it goes down another 10 20
30 that's the way you should be thinking
with the long term outlook and not
trying to trade uh these moves these
short term moves which nobody can do
completely agree where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
find out more about compound
yeah just check out best places twitter
check out uh
charlie balo uh i just started a youtube
channel
as well where i'm doing a few videos
with a lot of charts uh and a lot of
data and and trying to be as objective
as possible uh so yeah that's the best
place uh definitely an avenues letter as
well or sent out once a week just you
know highlighting the most important
charts and themes and markets uh and
investing and again the big big thing
for me is just educating and trying to
be helpful to people
uh in terms of you know this is hard
this is a hard investing is the hardest
business there is
as you know so you know you're not alone
it's and these are difficult times and
and just try to keep your keep your
sensibilities
uh and have some context that this too
shall pass we'll get through this uh
it's it's going to there'll be better
days ahead uh for sure and and sometimes
it's hard when you're living in that
it's hard to
it's hard to believe that it will but uh
we'll get there and so that's that's the
big message for sure i could not agree
more my friend uh i really enjoyed this
we're definitely gonna have to do this
again in the future so keep up the great
work anyone who doesn't follow charlie
on twitter uh i highly suggest you do
that uh i've learned a ton i think you
will as well so uh thanks so much for
your time charlie and we'll do it again
thank you thanks for having me have a
good